mit aromahopfen und speziellen hilfen
will die industrie das perfekte
alkoholfreie bier entwickelt haben
sebastian lege wirft einen blick in den
braukessel und testet ob ein
trachtenverein das alkoholfreie bier
herausschmecken kann künftig im brauhaus
trifft läge die bierfreunde der
trachtengruppe augsburg normalerweise
kommt bei ihnen nur gerstensaft mit
prozenten ins glas aber werden sie auch
in einer blindverkostung alkoholfreie
biere von normalen unterscheiden können
sebastian lege macht den test er
serviert sechs verschiedene biere davon
nur drei mit alkohol und tatsächlich sie
sicher identifizieren unsere tester die
alkoholfreien und schmeckt
das schmeckt nicht okay wer
alkoholfreies bier braut steht vor einer
herausforderung das deutsche
reinheitsgebot erlaubt als zutaten nur
wasser gerste hopfen und hefe künstliche
aromen oder zugesetzte
geschmacksverstärker sind tabu im
normalen bier aber verstärkt der alkohol
die natürlichen aromen gleiche zutaten
aber weniger alkohol
traditionell wird bei der herstellung
von alkoholfreiem bier die hefe stark
gekühlt damit sie weniger alkohol
freisetzt und während die gärung von
normalem bier eine ganze woche dauert
wird sie beim alkoholfreien schon nach
einem tag gestoppt das ergibt statt 5
prozent nur 0,5 prozent alkohol
die hefezellen im normalen bier setzen
während der einen woche derzeit aber
nicht nur alkoholfrei sondern auch
reichlich aromastoffe davon entstehen
bei der kühl und kurz kairo deutlich
weniger
die alternative man nimmt normales bier
und entfernt den alkohol durch
destillation doch auch hier geht aroma
flöten am ende hat man ein bier mit 0
prozent alkohol um die aroma verluste
auszugleichen setzen einige hersteller
wie das brauhaus riegele auf
verschiedene tricks
aber was genau tun sie damit ihr
alkoholfreies wirklich mit
alkoholhaltigen bieren mithalten kann
sebastian lege will sich das vor ort mal
genauer anschauen
so jetzt geht's los am anfang steht wie
bei jedem wir ein sud aus gersten mikes
je mehrmals desto mehr alkohol entsteht
später bei der gärung
deshalb lautet der erste trick es kommt
gerade so vielmals in den kessel dass es
würze gibt und nur ganz wenig alkohol
[Musik]
und dann kommt die seele des bieres der
hopfen reich an bitterstoffen und den
wildesten aromen schwärmt hopfenbauer
widmen
wenn man hier richtig wohl und glaube
dass ich eine ananas citrus also aus
diesen töpfen kommen wir brauchen diesen
sehr toll schmeckt über 20 hopfensorten
werden in deutschland angebaut
traditionsbrauerei aber setzen auf
bewährtes und ändern möglichst wenig an
ihrer rezeptur doch fehlt der
geschmacksträger alkohol im bier kann
das nur ein spezieller aromahopfen
ausgleichen sich wahnsinn das ist das
laufen es ist ein mittel früh genau
zu den topfen verletzten aromahopfen
weil diese sorte anfälliger für
krankheiten und damit teurer im am bau
war geriet sie in vergessenheit
doch dank ihres besonders würzigen aroma
erlebt wie nun ein kampf ich weiß es
einfach rein ohne glas wird seine suppe
aber es gibt noch eine zutat die
entscheidet ob das alkoholfreie schmeckt
wie ein echtes die hefe wie verwandelt
das malz in alkohol und sorgt für den
unverwechselbaren biergeschmack genau
hier wendet die industrie deshalb ihren
wichtigsten trick an
mikrobiologen tüfteln an speziellen hefe
kulturen
die produzieren nur wenig alkohol dafür
aber besonders ausgeprägte aromen das
arsenal der züchter ist enorm
manche häfen sorgen für fruchtige oder
exotische note der clou häfen mit minz
aromen die sich im mund leicht scharf
anfühlen wie alkohol eben doch ein
prozent restalkohol ist immer noch zu
viel
die lösung es wird jetzt so viel 0,0
prozent ihr beigemischt bis die
gesetzlich geforderten 0,5 prozent
unterschritten werden
beim wein ist so ein sorten verschnitt
als cuvée schon lange üblich für
biertrinker noch ziemlich gewagt
aber am schluss zählt nur ob sich die
mühen gelohnt haben
der härtetest halten die augsburger
bierfreunde das städtchen in der
blindverkostung für ein bier mit oder
ohne alkohol
[Musik]
sie liegen gleich mit und schmerz würde
endlich weg na also geht doch
alkoholfreie biere holen geschmacklich
auf dank neuer innovativer braut tricks
inzwischen setzen viele marken auf
hightech häfen und super hopfen selbst
die hippe kraft bier szene erfrischt
sich mit alkoholfreien elz und einige
entschärfte weizenbiere überzeugten
sogar die stiftung warentest gut auch
für figurbewusste denn sie enthalten
rund 40 prozent weniger kalorien als die
alkoholhaltige konkurrenz na dann prost
schmeckt euch alkoholfreies bier sagt es
uns in den kommentaren
ihr seid ihr die weinliebhaber dann
zeigt euch sebastian worauf sie beim
kauf achten sollte und wollte noch mehr
über essen wissen dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut woher das tk
gemüse kommt